وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه عبد الرحمن خليل
ان اتصالات تجري مع دول غربيه ابدت رغبتها
في اجلاء رعاياها من الخرطوم بينها
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا
والمانيا وان الترتيبات جاريه مع الخارجيه
السودانيه ونقلت وكانت الانباء الالمانيه
عما وصفتها بمصادر السودانيه مطلعه قولها
ان اجلاء رعايا عدد من الدول سيتم خلال
الهدنه المعلنه واشارت المصادر الى اجراء
مشاورات لتحديد مطار في مدينه عطبره كبديل
مؤقت لمطار الخرطوم لتسهيل عمليه الاجلاء
جهه اعلنت قوات دعم السريه استعدادها لفتح
جميع مطارات السودان امام حركه الملاحه
الجويه بشكل جزئيا لتمكين الدول التي تود
اجلاء رعاياها من نقلهم بالسلام اضافت
قوات دعم السريع ان الخطوه تاتي تماشيا مع
الهدنه الانسانيه التي اعلنتها لاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه والتي بدات صباح الجمعه سعيا
لتسهيل حركه المواطنين والمقيمين واضافت
قوات دعم السريع انها مستعده للتعاون
والتنسيق وتقديم كل التسهيلات التي تمكن
الجاليات والبعثات من مغادره البلاد بامان